max knows someone who knows someone who
knows someone you gas masks I know it's
not real but it smells big spider can
you shine the light on me bro good
morning guys this morning we're gonna go
deep under the streets of Kyiv Ukraine
in search of an abandoned Cold War
bunker now the guy max that's taking us
there left me a message this morning
saying it's cold wet tight and hard core
and if there's one thing I've learned
about living in this country when a
Ukrainian says hardcore you take them
seriously
[Music]
[Music]
max
Rasmus has literally Takada same what is
your name it up Peter
we're going in deep right that's right
we're gonna check out the biggest
underground quarter all Ukraine first
well then we should climb to the top of
the hill and get into their long as and
harvest blabbering this one leads to the
all the system in keep one of the oldest
built in 1916 by the order of nicholas
ii who used to be at our of russian in
peru and it's blocked
whoo that's cold huh
now I brought a sweatshirt
and once it's yours okay
just mind your head inside we have lots
of sharp bricks and other stuff for the
ceiling maybe layers can be here okay
interesting yeah so such tunnels we can
everywhere I can even use is a similar
system on the pitch esque where all the
most expensive the buildings are and I
can get to the highly guarded closed
parkings underground parkings they have
connections to all solve it a drainage
systems and it's possible to pull up
ahead so you can go underneath people's
houses yeah and like pop up in their
property near it usually we go we don't
do this hey I want our target is not to
break into someone's house yeah
buildings or doors awoke we are not
breaking yeah head of someone's swing
flips wow that's cool when was this
built these in 1916 everything is made
of yellow bricks but you cannot see them
because everything is covered by morning
layers memory
it's cold in here guys quite cool place
here yeah yeah okay I forgot to warn you
- yeah I'm good guys I spent quite some
time in this position we're coming here
we're pretty far under now yet
[Music]
echoing everything that going I was
expecting some real dirty rat-infested
sewer water environment but instead it's
okay absolutely whatever coming closer
yes dad you can't even hear water side
so the waterfalls up here
I like it brother
yeah we all do it
[Music]
well what's in there go instruction from
time to time to client natural
stalactites and stalagmites which is
like animate your okay and we can notice
different colors
the counter defense of what type of
mineral line right above our heads we
can iron salt for
[Music]
like so we been coming down here for
them
for seven years
well can we she is going
the water
it's an extra extra soil is about all
okay yeah
right too late for direct shock wave and
the sound wave on us so it's gonna be
super loud super loud so we need to
close our ears I can have that hold them
just to feel that echo spread u4q meters
and kilometers are all under the city
even closer to the entrance it's
possible to explode
holy [ __ ] this is a true adventure oh
we're getting smoked out here man like
you guys have parties down there in the
new city polluted sedated society this
is it's impossible to fly in such a
clear water this level which is not in
use no more here you can see this
traditional old South's the Russians
letters in the end of two words we hold
[Music]
so like so much of Ukraine it's know a
guy who knows a guy who can make the
excess happen
so that's what you said right there's
some old guy up there now we're going to
this similar construction a whole sort
of Garden District race is guarded the
third place is very much is the most
serious today Gamesmaster where
careful
this van rolled on the our kills they
have space levels right and every stair
has its own system of tunnels so we were
basically under this hillside yes we
were in the deepest system in this
region okay it's a lot of bushwhacking
to get to these locations
so max how do you know these places
you know everything your 20 year 25 I
know everything about here playground Oh
fighters know about the place they bring
their friends they leave rubbish inside
just another day in cave huh the cities
get a few were not expected yeah the
city's got so many sides to it you know
more challenging that that one
ready ready come on let's get in there
so what's in here
I should remember is a way now it seems
like what's at the end of this one I
guess this time you just have to keep
calm in the mind okay so turn yet turn
around and come back to the crossroad
all right
how's it look max fine big spider can
you shine the light on me bro somebody
said further I totally want it you want
it looking like a casual try yeah they
are I wanted Max's deep knowledge sure
and even I've pushed that because you
don't know where we are right this is so
it with cement and lisas sauce made of
yellow right and you can see that little
inlets for the candles right from ready
for putting candles do you think
[Music]
yeah whoa it's cool man
doesn't really show up well guys but
this is massive
it's nice to have this space like some
breathing room there's a workout that
was like 30 minutes coming in here okay
we're gonna do fireworks in here and
this is this gonna be the first time you
can hi there and I will fight there
put it up here do you climb up this
[Music]
light guys this is pretty it's pretty
raw quite venturous and I don't know if
many cities have anything like this I'm
sure they do but as far as accessing
this sort of stuff
max was saying you don't want to come
down here in the silver because if the
rains come these places get flooded out
and then I said to max isn't it this
summer
but no problem so I've trusted in fully
good sup here we go almost to the top
here Wow
all the way
[Music]
not one for the claustrophobic but if
you want a bit of an adventure this kind
of stuff is pretty damn cool what else
is cool as I Fisher saw these little
secret lays in and then we're off to the
nuclear bunker and Max was saying nobody
knows about it as far as how to get in
there and there's one old guy he's got a
relationship with and that sort of is
that's the next time whoa okay now three
percent sorry fest three percent so fold
it three percent of all the tunnels in
the whole city that was work out that
was deep
now the most interested bomb interest
we're canvassing through the forest
going up to the road here so the whole
reason behind having all these tunnels
is to
is to keep the train is going so that
whole side doesn't loss all these roles
are available or buildings building
parks and monuments every since
because the hills get pretty steep there
right it's it's unbelievable the Czar's
actually had that foresight right like
it started in Zara's time okay we're in
see her location maximum secret nobody
knows where we are on the outside so max
knows someone who knows someone Ukranian
style and so we're in and this is this
is the sylvia cold war-era bunker right
yeah this is the gym
how do cold for long term full of a
great wonderful spiders spiders we are
getting into the emergency exit so this
is not the main entrance view use black
entrance but no it's in the middle of
the city in the middle is a seat behind
it rather be right near the apartment
blocks and a part but I'd like to tell
you this is unusual bunker why because
it was constructed like an underground
laboratory it has huge Faraday cages
inside there no what is it
no Farley cage it's like a special is
elated room made of metal usually to
protect different electronic equipment
from radio magnetic waves for example
because after the nuclear strike
hydrogen magnetic field appears in here
and this radial magnetic field can cause
problems for electronic devices
everything dies and this is an institute
of statistic they have their own back up
laboratory in this bunker which massive
ancient computers with punch cards not
programs after the nuclear bra blast the
blast wave is getting into this tunnel
then these blows no stops
and these pens close down and open after
pressure of the air falls down so when
did this stop being occupied 91
absolutely right the later they led by
the way to make you point so they just
left all this stuff so how many of these
are in keep 400 bunkers but only 20% are
still maintained what's that noise water
yeah all cables yeah so just
instructions on how to suit up if
there's a nuclear attack you're right
can you recognize oh yeah yeah look at
the date 1977 here you're touching the
original stuff not in a museum yeah but
in the original left in the original
place nowadays it's quite hard to find
such an touch to building bunkers not
destroyed whereas ants mysterion
all right
so how many people would would be down
here so the Soviet Union fell apart and
everyone just sort of abandoned yeah all
these posts huh but here you can find
even more than documents from the model
history like 2010-2011 1981
what is this document it's all about
that factory's about salaries of workers
about you know what is it
the Attili odka 5 years plan right
accountant 5 years plan is doing
planning Institute of planning plans
here this by the way I'm not joking 5
years plan now is buried here forever
here's the seal and better to use these
to do life it's American nuclear weapons
the poster is a handmade one come closer
and touch it's painted it's made by
hands so you know for all others
uniforms almost impossible nowadays in
Kiev to find such a good preserved and
fully abandoned bunker yeah there's an
easy access similar condition can be
found only under still very well guarded
military factories and plants right but
not easy access huh you have you have to
you have to know how to get in here yes
but still I can get in some places you
need to
new gas masks brand view straight from
1986
maybe we need these for coronavirus I
see people walking in them drop a month
ago completely untouched command not a
command center meeting Center small that
it's wet but time has stopped
yeah what is a real place without alarm
going to forget Lenin over there yeah he
said propaganda poster right December 19
see every table belongs to different
workers this is a medical crew chief
State Building guy responsible for ever
creation was India so we're right below
the Institute right now yes but now it's
a business center business center right
above us
they have no idea it's under here
what's going on here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is for medical training lag Don's
yeah I know it's not real but it by Rudy
I know it's not real but it smells these
things what is that this is a
decontamination liquid flag anxious
bottles some powders you need to prepare
a special decontamination liquid and
clean your closures after coming back
from the country
this is definitely an interesting day
max nothing had a normal day but there
never is a normal day in the same you
can pretty much connect a lot of these
buildings sure underneath into the into
the wall you can find behind some yellow
cables you can find the same cables
inside of a ventilation shaft on the
right when you are breaking the wall in
order to get from another room enclosure
so that's that's the alarm system an
alarm system even ventilation shaft is
full of them
right yeah no one could even crawl
through the ventilation well that's it
guys that's a day underneath Keith mag
solid solid discovery I'm properly tired
and beat up a good job Peter we're all
done today thank you brother
so a keith has tons going on above
ground but underneath I didn't know
until today is this whole new world max
is your man if you need to go under I'll
leave your Instagram
in the description with 30 years in this
hobby so for sure we had lots of things
to show
that was awesome thank you for the visit
one more time not many people do this
well like you you did well her face it's
a real at the ground firework first
couple of crazy explosions
bunker deeds really good it's a nuclear
official area hell yeah
sure espresso alright guys until next
video I got a lot more in keep coming
and then greater Ukraine okay in a in a
car and get out as well the other areas
until next one
so whenever we fest 1% of their policies
become universal